[Music]
the [ __ ] is ridiculously big or did you
not think it was that big I thought it
was pretty big I thought here's what's
hard to say and this is not like an out
honestly cuz I'll talk about online
bloops dick all day well it's hard to
without knowing the proportions of
someone's body right all together from a
photo it's kind of hard because now I
don't know his dick is very well
proportioned to his body his dick is big
and he's a big dude so I'm gonna say he
has a big dick you wouldn't be on a
paddleboard with your [ __ ] out if you
didn't have a big right in a second
you're like in doing something most
people would be doing with clothes on
that you opted not to wear close up with
you have a big dick is it a master plan
to get guys like you to say oh yeah
Orlando Bloom haven't thought about that
guy in a while maybe I'll put him in
something you know maybe is that the
move I'd be lying if I said I wasn't
more inclined to put him in something I
saw he has a great dick I think the
philosophy might be like it's a
competitive market I'm I'm Orlando Bloom
I've been great for years but you know
what there's all these new kids out
there there's these there's the Jamie
Dornan of the world out there coming up
maybe I got to show my dick make people
remember Orlando Bloom's of [ __ ] OG
if two guys are up for a part why not
choose the guy with the big day exactly
conscious level people will probably buy
more tickets to the big dick guy